Well, I know your camera's tilted a little down and I'm noticing your legs. You're wearing some shorts today. Thank you. By the way, Fritzvall, let me just say thank you. 40 degrees outside. Thank you so much. I appreciate the compliment. Why do you wear shorts?
Have you not been outside the house to do drop off at all today? Thanks again. I just want to say for me, it's hard to take so much credit. Obviously, the man upstairs sculpted these babies, but... Wait, you live in a duplex? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha That looks badass. Doesn't that look good? You can't hear this yet. Damn.
And we have Will Audio, Shawnee Joining, Shawnee Joining. Really? I think that looks fucking badass. Do you? Yeah, I didn't go with that. I think it looks great. We are rolling, surprise the guests, give us a little clap if you don't mind.
All right, we're rolling. Jewelry, have fun. I might do it, I was doing a little test for this new thing I'm doing, and I might do it. I might do it, I might keep it, I don't know. I think that's the winner right there. Yeah. Jesus. It's all about-
It's a fucking bone structure. How do you get fucking bone structure with a haircut? Yeah. I don't know, man. I guess it's just, hang on, I looked it up before. Genetics. Genetics. Genetics.
Sorry. That's really good. Fucking great. Really good. I love seeing you, JB, in the full vest, in the down vest this morning. It's coming off the slopes. Oh, no, I just, this is just a carpool drop-off,
whatever you call it, school drop-off. What are these kids, what are my kids' names? Yeah, I know. What's a young one? Tell me the young one's name. Maple's the name. That's Maple. That's your drop-off.
Fresh back from drop off. Yeah. This is post drop off pre shower, pre G4, handsome golf outfit. Oh, so you do have golf today. So you're going to take a shower before? I will be taking a shower. Yes. Getting it all nice and powder dry. Clean.
You know our buddy Skip Bronson. Skip Bronson saw him yesterday swinging it over there. He claimed that we're the visor twins. Cause you and I. I do like a visor. Yeah. I like a visor cause I feel like this big dumb head of crazy hair can't fit into a cap nowadays.
I like your new look by the way. We were talking about it, Jay. Your new look is sort of rugged. They were both trying on some new looks for parts coming on. I'm supposed to be looking like a ex-drummer, drug addict, loser, and I'm really kind of nailing it with this stupid long hair and facial hair. I look like I'm playing a hooligan, like a soccer hooligan.
Yeah, yeah. You know what I mean? What do I look like I'm playing? Now, careful, well, be nice, well. Like a 53-year-old Illinois house husband. Yeah, it's a family after school special about a 50-year-old that's going back to elementary school because he just didn't get fifth grade right.
And body swaps. There's going to be a body swap, right? Well, there's going to be a lot of body swap. JB's done a body swap. He's got a lunch pail. Yeah, I did a body swap movie. Yeah. Me and Ryan Reynolds pissed into a magic fountain
and you know what happens. And then you decided to do a movie together? What happened? Oh, well, this guy, he's really on me today. He's getting me, huh? Shawna, you got some texts coming through, Shawna, you wanna just take care of them? I'm trying to find the photo of my shaved head.
I can't find it. Are you advertising for Brentwood Country Mart? What is that? What are you just saying? This is where I like to find it. Are you advertising for Brentwood Country Mart? What is that? What are you just saying? This is where I like to eat most. Hey, welcome back to hashtag relatable. This week we're going over markets. Anybody can go to the Brentwood Country Mart.
It's fantastic. Is that their tagline? It's fantastic. Boy, they didn't put a lot of thought into that. It's terrific. It's dynamite. It is very good. I do want to speak about dynamite. It is very good. All right, Will.
I do want to speak about dynamite. I want to speak about dynamite because this, our guest today is nothing. Is dynamite? Well, nothing short of dynamite. Let me just say that much and I'll tell you why. She's explosive. We do know it's a she, I heard a giggle
and I heard some jewelry on the clap. Oh, you did? Yeah, I heard a gig. Yep. You heard a gig too. Where is everybody hearing all these gigs? Yeah, I heard a gig. Yep. You heard a gig too. Where's everybody hearing all these gigs? Well, we've got actual headphones on. You've got snazzy earbuds. I don't know, man. I just, I don't know how I missed the gig anyway. I, um, this is something.
Oh man, this is so good. Yeah, take your time. Well, I was just going to say, so we get a lot of, we get, we get, we get, oh, there. Oh, look at just gonna say so we get a lot of She is ready. She's a singer. I tell you why she's ready because this is somebody who's got you know, we've had we've had award-winning Actors and actresses and performers and directors But imagine being nominated for four Academy Awards and winning one imagine it imagine being nominated for two BAFTAs and winning one Imagine being nominated for god damn it. I get winning one. Imagine being nominated for me for Golden Globes five SAG awards. Yeah. Are you starting to get what I'm throwing down you guys? Yeah, you're starting to get that. Because this person has done some of the greatest biggest films
of all time. Some of the most cool independent films, thought provoking films. She's done it all. She is somebody that I have admired for a long time, me and the rest of the world. I don't know how else to say other than to say, guys, it's Penelope Cruz. Oh, wow.
Can you believe it? I mean, this is... What is that? It's a royal tea on the market. It's a royal tea. Look at her go. Penelope. Hi. Oh, look at her go. Hail royalty. Hi.
Hi. What an amazing presentation. I don't think I deserve that, but thank you so much. Oh my gosh, it's absolutely true. Hello. Well, all of it's true. Nice to meet you. Good morning.
Nice to meet you too. Nice to meet you. Thank you for joining us. Where do we, we're not in your bedroom, we're in a hotel room. Are we not? Where are we? This is actually not my bedroom, we're in a hotel room, are we not? Where are we? This is actually not my bedroom.
That this is a room where they brought me to do the interview. Where are you, you're doing some press? We are in a hotel for a couple of days here in LA. Yeah. And going back home soon. She's doing, Penelope, and correct me if I'm wrong, you're here doing press for a Ferrari,
your new film that you've done with Michael Mann, is that true? Yes, yes, true. Which is fantastic, and we had the pleasure of meeting one of your co-stars, Adam Driver, and we're very excited for Ferrari. Yeah, I can't wait to see it. But I'm really excited to talk to you, Penelope,
about just what an incredibly diverse career that you've had, that you've carved out. And I kind of want to touch on something, I'm so excited you're here by the way. I want to talk about- I mean too, I think this is wild. There's a story that I picked up on. I saw an interview you did with Terry Gross on Fresh Air
and it really piqued my interest. And guys, I don't know if you know this. And I'd love for you to speak to this. You talk about, you were a big fan of Pedro Almotivar, right? Fantastic fan, the great Spanish filmmaker. And you would tell your friends, you were putting yourself in a position to see him. You're not necessarily waiting outside his house,
but you would go to restaurants. Also, also I did. But you did wait outside his house. That's something I would go. Yeah, a couple of times. Yeah, like a cycle. A couple of times, and then would go to bars and restaurants and wait, and your friends But you did wait outside his house. That's something I would go. He had a couple of times. Yeah, me too. A couple of times and then would go to bars and restaurants and wait and your friends thought you were insane
and you said, believe me, I have this connection and it will happen. Can you talk to us a little bit about that blue one? Yes, what is that? I know for a lot of people it can sound weird and also it sounded crazy to him when I told him for the first few years he didn't believe me. And then a lot of things like that started to happen between him and I.
And I think by now, like 30 years later, he believes me. We have a very special connection and I was a huge fan of his work. You know, I didn't have a theater, a cinema near where we lived, because we lived outside Madrid and I developed love for movies and different actresses and directors through the Betamax machine that my father and my mother bought when I was like a kid. You remember how heavy and big the Betamax was. So I asked them to give me a copy of the cards for the video store.
And I was there every afternoon after school and after my homework and my dance classes. What I wanted to do is be alone and watch a movie. If I liked a movie, I would watch it 20 times in a row. Like really study that film. And that's how I discovered Pedro and Spielberg and Scorsese and Billy Wilder and... So what were you filming those movies
that you would watch 20 times? Like that you love, love, love as a kid? I mean, I always knew I wanted to act, but I had no, apart from the couple of hours that I spent doing classical ballet, that was like very hardcore, but at the same time it was a way of acting, and a way to release that need that I had of
visiting and investigating different ways of being and different realities And I think I would have been very damaged if I didn't have that but then I discovered that that was like a window to the world, you know, like I could dream about a that was like a window to the world. You know, like I could dream about a what that life would be like or this or that and put yourself in somebody else's shoes. And I felt like this is what I want to do in my life.
I don't know how. I didn't know anybody related to the business, anybody that could make a living out of something related to arts. When I said that to my parents, it was like saying I want to be an astronaut. It was very surreal for them. I just appreciate that they didn't invalidate me.
They didn't laugh. They said, you can try if that's what you want. We'll pay your dance classes and then your theater classes, but have a plan B because probably this won't work. So through that Betamax machine, I started planning. But I mean, imagine that, I mean, you say that, right. It's like saying to your parents, I wanna go live on the moon.
You grew up in a small town outside of Madrid. You don't even have a theater. And all your connection to films is through renting Betamax. Yes. And then you, but you have this dream All your connection to films is through Rending Betamax films. Yes. Yes. But you have this dream, and lots of people have dreams that they,
I wanna do this, I wanna do that. But the follow through is so precise to the point that you're like, you identify, well, Sean had asked like, what were the films that really inspired you? And I do wanna get that, but you identify specifically as you get older
that you know that you want to connect to Pedro. Yes. And that you're like, the follow through, and like you said, for some people it might seem weird, but you knew that there was something there. You thought you were pretty confident that like, once he meets me, I know we're gonna have a connection.
He seems like the kind of guy I would get along with. And you just courted And you just put yourself in front of him? Yeah, not because I thought I was good, just because I thought that he saw the world in a very similar way to the way that I saw it since I was a little girl. And actually, I got into one of the sets without permission when I was 14 and he was doing... No, when I was like 15, 16, he was doing high heels and he was shooting with Victoria Abril, one of my favorite actresses. And I just walked in, nobody stopped me.
I sat very close to the monitor, nobody said anything. And he looked at me and I said, oh my God, he's gonna say something. He just looked at me for a few seconds, like, do I know you? We know each other. That was enough for me for that day to be able to spy and be there for a couple of hours. But then when, because he was the one,
like you said before, such a specific dream, he was the one that I wanted to meet, to thank, and to be able to maybe one day work with him. So when I did my first two movies, I got that phone call. My two first movies were very different from each other, Bellapok and Hamon Hamon, and I was very lucky to have that presentation card, because the characters were like day and night,
and that was important to come to start that way. And somebody said to me, Almodóvar is on the phone. And I was drawing my hair, preparing for classes. And I said, yeah, right. Almodóvar is on the phone. And it took me like five minutes to react because I thought, how can in,
is it for real that dreams so specific can become a reality and he was there and his voice was like, oh, this old friend that I haven't seen for a long time and the connection was instant. I lied to him about my age. We did the casting for the movie. It was not appropriate for my age, the movie.
So the casting was just a conversation about like, really how old are you? I know you were lying to me. So I said, yeah, actually, yes, I'm like at that point, I think 18, he said this character has to be at least 25 or 30, but I will write a character for you in my next film and he did. Jesus, and this is,
imagine getting that call, Sean it would be like you if they, if they're like, Sean, Kraft McGroney and cheese is on the phone. And you'd be like, I had like dreams come true. Kraft McGroney and cheese is not on the phone. Like if you have a specific chain, you can come.
He loves food. Penelope. Me too. But. So Penelope, what about when you filled him in on this story about that you've been following him around? Did he, was he charmed by that? Did he laugh?
Did he remember you being at the monitor when you were 15? No, not that, but then I told him, look, one time at the cinema, I told my friends that I was gonna find you that day. And it was just a random cinema by the time that I was able to go to the cinema alone when I was older. And my friend couldn't believe it
because by the end of the movie, we came out and he was there in the street. And a lot of things like that. At the beginning, he was looking at me like, yeah, right. Okay, you are very young and you are believing all. But now he does. You can ask him and now he does. Like these things happen between him and I.
That's cool. So how many films have you done with him now? Seven. Seven. And I hope many more. I just talked to him this morning. Wow, that's amazing. He's one of the greatest. He's one of the loves of my life. He's much more than a director I work with. He's family. Sure, of course.
And he is hilarious. And you have to invite him here because he will make you laugh so much. It would be like a dream come true. He's one of the great directors and he's one of the great imaginations, one of the great storytellers. And then the guys know I don't use that term lightly. Wow. But before you worked with him, you had done two films, right? Before you worked with Pedro.
What was it like at that point? What were the opportunities like in Spain for you at that point in the Spanish film industry. Was there a lot going on? Was it robust? Was it difficult? It was like a miracle that I found my agent. When I found my agent, she's now 83,
and we've been together since I was 14, 15. The first time I went to see her, she sent me home. She said, what are you doing here? You're too young. Please go away. I came back the week after. She said the same thing to me. I came back the week after. And then I asked her to let me do an improv, where I could just play somebody that was very angry. And in my improv, I was actually an actress
that was talking about her dreams. I was asking for an opportunity, even if I was young. And then I was the only person that she picked that year to be represented and out of 300 people. And we're still together, you know? And I love her so much. She started to send me to castings and to my surprise. I got a yes as an answer.
I could not believe it. I mean, it got a yes as an answer. I could not believe it. I mean, it was a big surprise to me. Penelope, all the dreams that you had about, I hope it happens. I wanna meet Pedro, I want my career to take off. I wanted all the dreams you had, all the aspirations that you had. You now, I would assume, have them even bigger
than you even dreamed back then. Is it what you thought it would be? Do you tell... What's your favorite part about what has become and what part of it did you not anticipate coming and you could kind of do without? That part is... I didn't think it would be bad like that. What's your favorite part? What's your least favorite part? My favorite part about this profession and the one that gives me a real happiness that can last and that is based on hard work
and the values that I think my parents taught me is the part that you are new each time you are starting from zero. You never get to a place where you feel you have things under control. You are like a constant student. You're never gonna do the same role twice or maybe you will but that's a different story. But you are gonna be challenged each time and have fear each time. And I feel like we could have this conversation when I'm 90 and I would still feel the same way. And I feel that's good for me, it's good for my mental health. It keeps me sane, it keeps me humble because it's about the learning process, it's about how we really are just one more piece of the puzzle when we are on the set
We cannot do this this work alone and this is Amazing about me my about my profession and I realized is what attracted me to it from day one The thing that I was surprised is that there was the element of attraction to fame when I was a teenager. I thought like, wow, like really? Me? They are saying this or that. But still, you get kind of a dopamine high from it, especially if you are very young, but that doesn't last. That goes away. And if you are evolving in a good way and you have a family around you that is going to be telling you the truth and cutting all the bullshit, and on top of that you become a mother when, of course, you will never see yourself as the first of the line ever again.
The priorities will change immediately for the rest of your life. You're not the number one on the call sheet at home. Yeah. You know what I mean? No, never. But for the rest of my life, I're not the number one on the call sheet at home. Yeah. You know what I mean? No, never, but for the rest of my life, I will never be and I don't want to. And that's like the biggest amount of happiness in my life comes from that.
And I realized that because I started so young, then when I was like 20 something, I had already gone through a lot of like emotions related to that to, oh, what is it, to get that attention. And one thing is to get a feeling of satisfaction if you're getting a good review or recognition from your peers because you've worked on something and you were so scared about it and you have connected.
And that is a real thing. Okay. But the other thing that I was flipping out about when I was, I don't know, 17, 18, 19, it doesn't last long. Those years I was surprised. So how come I don't feel the same thing as I felt three years ago? That doesn't last forever. No, it lasts very little.
It's like a friend of mine, a psychiatrist friend of mine was saying, it's actually one having a very, being very exposed to fame at a very young age is one of the things that can put you on higher risk for depression. And it makes total sense because at the end of the day, it's like when you are super addicted to a video game or gambling, or it's like this high that will have a dramatic drop and it's just dopamine and it is like that. Yeah. And we will be right back.
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So one of the relationships I'm most proud of is the one between me and Scotty. We've been together 17 years. That's a long time, isn't it? But it takes work to be in any relationship for that long. And if you do the work, the rewards are just numerous and incredible and you end up being closer than ever.
And it really worth doing the work to stay in it. Because a common misconception about relationships is they have to be easy to be right. But sometimes the best ones happen when both people put in the work to make them great together. So therapy can be a place to work through the challenges you face in all your relationships, whether it's with friends, work,
your significant other, or anyone. We don't do couples therapy, we've never done couples therapy, but we do separate therapy and it always works great. And when we get back together, we learn from therapy and it only makes our relationship stronger and healthier. It really, really works.
If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Become your own soulmate whether you're looking for one or not. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. Our thanks to Stitch Fix for supporting this episode.
This year you can make great style effortlessly easy with Stitch Fix. Stitch Fix stylists just get you. They do all the work giving you the time to focus on your resolutions and everything else on your plate. Stitch Fix is an easy way to get clothes that fit you without having to endlessly browse through options or break the bank. Think of them as your style partner. Your stylist will learn about your tastes and collaborate with you on looks you'll love. With your choices in mind and a wide range of sizes available, from extra small to 3XL,
they'll find your perfect fit and send you clothes hand-picked just for you. They have over a thousand brands and styles and do the work of choosing the best options for you. They'll even show you how to wear head-to-toe outfits so you can just get dressed and go. And if you don't love something, just send it back. Shipping returns and exchanges are always free.
I love the convenience of Stitch Fix myself. I took the quiz, they kind of lined me up with everything that I love. I talked to a stylist and I got my fix on. I just, because I can't dress myself. It's really, really sad. If it was up to me, I'd wear sweats and a T-shirt every day, but I can't walk out of the house that way. So Stitch Fix helps me with everything. Thanks, Stitch Fix. They just get me and they'll get you to try it today at stitchfix.com slash smartlist and you'll get 25% off when you keep everything in your fix that stitchfix.com slash smartlist.
Stitchfix.com slash smartlist. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Helix. So guys, we've been talking about Helix for a long time now. I just ordered another one, the Midnight Lux. It's awesome. It's got like a medium feels, it's not too soft, not too hard, my Goldilux. And then it also has, it's good for side sleepers like I am.
I never sleep on my stomach or my back really. And it's got enhanced lumbar for my back when I sleep on my side. It's got great support, I love it. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids Hélix SleepQuiz.com. straight to your door free of charge. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a 100 night trial
and a 10 to 15 year warranty to try out your new Helix mattress. Helix is offering 20% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless and use code Helixpartner20. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. Helixsleep.com slash smartlist code Helixpartner20
with Helix Better Sleep starts now. All right, back to the show. I think you put it in the right place when I remember telling my kids I have three boys and a stepson. So four boys in the house, it's crazy. And I remember saying when my older boys were younger, sort of six, seven, and people want to take photos
or whatever when you're out. And I remember explaining that to them, and it was through explaining to them the idea of, these people don't know me, they think they do, they want my picture because they think something else. And when I said it out loud and put it in the right place, it changed everything for me once I actually said it out loud. And it put it in a place that was much more acceptable
and it stopped affecting, I've said this many times, as long as you don't peg your happiness to how other people think about you, then you'll be okay. And you can kind of keep that right sized. You know what I mean? Yeah. Keep it in the right place. And I was also thinking about that right size. You know what I mean? Yeah. Keep it in the right place. And I was also thinking about something else
you said Penelope, which is interesting. And I don't know, I'm gonna open this up to everybody. Really, you're talking about staying a student. And I've been thinking so much more in the last couple of years now that I'm 53. I mean, I could play 48, but. Yeah, easily. Thank you.
Maybe even 48. No, I'm 40. Sure, maybe 40. Thank you. I really appreciate it.. Sure, maybe 40, thank you. I really appreciate it. But one of the things I've been thinking about is this idea of staying, I was saying to somebody, I want to stay in the student section of life, not just in my work.
I want to really feel, I don't want to be an expert, and like all of us, I can talk like an expert sometimes about stuff and have a lot of conviction. It's so important in this life to stay in the student section, I think. Don't you agree? I agree. I agree.
And I feel like when you have kids, immediately you are putting that place forever because it's such a lesson every day and so much wisdom that comes from just the total honesty that all the kids have. Yeah, they don't care. It's a great reminder that you know nothing until you learn it. Like you get to watch them learn things
or get experience with things for the very first time. And we forget that moment for us. For instance, somebody sent us a gift yesterday and there was like a cassette tape in it, one of those old audio cassette tapes. And my 12 year old daughter said, what's this? And I said, well, that's a cassette. She said a cassette, what's a cassette?
I said, well, it's a, I mean, how do you describe what a cassette is? I said, what's that? The same thing happened to me last month and I was shocked. She didn't know how to open up that cassette box, that clear see-through cassette box. And you said, this is what daddy used to put in his Shirako.
Yeah, exactly. I said, I used to have hundreds of these, these are what albums used to be on. She goes, really, this is, there's music on this? I said, yeah. I said, open it up and put it in. She's, it took five minutes. How did you have a big point?
There was a little, there was a little like a Walkman that came with the gift. No way. And it took her five minutes to open up. have a point? There was a little like a Walkman that came with the gift. No way. And it took her five minutes to open up. I finally had to take it from her. I said, let me show you how to open, she almost broke it. She didn't know how to open up the clip. Anyway, so yeah, it's a great reminder
that you just don't realize what you don't know if you don't keep up your radar that you're willing to learn. Also age helps, age helps not giving a shit. Like, right, the older you get, you're just like, I'm too tired and old to care. Well, you maybe start caring about things that are actually important. And all the things that are related
about how you are perceived. For sure. By people that you don't know, which is different than, of course, if you have a job like the one that we have, at the end of the day, you are doing that to try to move energy in people, to try to... we make movies for that reason, not to change the world, but you want to connect with people.
Yeah. I want to know, like, I want to go back to ballet. I had no idea about ballet. That's crazy This did you find that? How many years did you take ballet like 17? 17 years. Do you still dance? Well, when I get the chance to I Might do a musical soon again like I did nine. You were great in nine I went I thank you
I loved making that movie and I went back to dancing for like six months or something like that. So I'm always looking for reasons to go back. That's great. Wow, so you don't have the wear and tear on a person's body of 17 years of being on your toes. Yeah. Like you have any kind of like-
Your toes still hurt? Yeah. No, but I mean, I got used to that. You know, when you are bleeding and your nails are like, you lose them, they get really dark and then they fall off and you have to keep dancing and smiling. And the discipline that it gives you, it helped me a lot because I started to work
as an actress so young and I had the discipline from that that was so much harder than anything I have done. I'm sure. I can't believe it. You talked a little bit about, we're just sort of just to swing back to like what's important stuff. And I, so both you and your partner are film actors
and actors at the highest level and very much in demand. You've made lots of films. And yet now you've started a family and I presume that you still live in Spain, yeah? Or that you moved back. Like you spent very many years where you were doing like, it seemed like you did so many films,
and I listed off all the awards and nominations. And yet now, do you find yourself, have you put that in a different place now? Like now that you've moved, and you live in Europe, and you don't live a different place now, like now that you move and you live in Europe and you don't live here in Los Angeles and you've kind of, do you feel that you've been able to carve out a kind of a different life? Very different, very different.
Where the total priority, the number one priority is the family. Also most of my family, mom and sisters and most of them are there in Spain. My brother and nephew are here in LA and I miss them so much. But I mean, life always brings us here, like maybe in the summer, Christmas or both,
and come here for work. And I lived here for 15 years in LA and I loved it. But we just wanted to be there raising the children because family is very important for us. Yeah, yeah, of course. What's the atmosphere like there where you live in Spain with respect to Hollywood and the media and fame and paparazzi and all that kind of stuff? Can you live a very sort of normal in quotes life there
as opposed to here? Yes. Oh, good. Well, when I was here, I mean, there was a way to do it also. I mean, it depends what kind of place you go to, you know, you know how it is. And there I can do everything.
I can go to school, go to the supermarket, go to a public gym, go to everywhere, everywhere. And this is where I want, I could not give up having a normal life. Wait, you can go to a public gym? Of course, and I can go everywhere. And even if they do recognize you, do they treat celebrity with such reverence there
like they do here? I think it's a little too big here. No, I think it's not a surprise to see us there. So, and also everything ends up being close to the area where I grew up and it feels like if you knew all your neighbors, you know, it feels very easy going and people are very nice. And is Javier from the same area?
We was actually born in Canary Islands, but he was raised more in the city and I was raised more out of Madrid. But also in LA I had no problems where I lived here and I feel like it's more choosing where you go to. If you're gonna go to a place looking for attention or you go to a place so you can leave your day. It's the vibe you put out too, right?
Oh, it's also what you wear too. Like if you look all great and fabulous, or if you look like you're trying to hide with a hat and big glasses, people, you stand out like a sore thumb. You draw more attention. Yeah, but if you just like, if there's no hiding whatsoever,
it's just a little sweatshirt or something. Well, we had a guest on, one of our guests who's a friend of the show, I won't name him, but he had, years ago I'd gone to his house, one of the biggest film actors on the planet. And we went to his house and he said, and I was giving him a lift home.
And we get to his gate that was barely like a gate. And then he said, just punching the code. I said, what's the code for the 2468? I said, come on, man. No, 2468. And then you could walk around it if you want. We get up to his house and we walk in and the front door is open.
And I said, dude, what are you doing? You're crazy. I mean, this is guys like that. And he goes, I don't live like a prisoner. Right. And if I put that vibe out in the world. Yeah, yeah, it's true. It's true.
Probably take less attention like that. I totally, by the way, totally. I'm like, if somebody's gonna get me, they're gonna get me. If somebody's, you know. Well, why do you have that, you have that sign that says Sean Hayes lives here in front of your house. Yeah, but I mean, you can see behind some hedges.
Wait, listen, Penelope, before we go any further, I wanna ask you, and this is a tough question and you can feel free to not answer it when he always cut it out. Real Madrid or Atlético Madrid? You know what? I don't care. I know that, no, no, I mean, I do because
that's another thing that changes when you are a mother and suddenly you see they like football, but then you start loving football too. I have a family that is from a lethico family from Barcelona, club family from Real Madrid. And I think they're amazing teams, but I am loving everything more Real Madrid. What can I say?
Very, very good. I love, I love a huge football fan and I'm obsessed and actually like both those teams as well. They have great players. We're recording this right around the holiday season and are you a big holiday fan? Do you love Christmas or what? I don't know what you guys celebrate.
Do you guys go skiing? Do you like the beach instead? It's just about being with the family. And since I have my kids, I really see, I get to experience again Christmas like when I was little, and it's like having a second chance like to experience it, to experience that magic
and it's incredible. Of course. I love it again so much. For a few years I, it was just like one more part of the year, but now it's a big deal. It's become a big deal. My three year old this morning, he was saying that he wanted to get this truck.
It was like a crane thing. And I said, okay, well, we'll see if Santa comes in. He goes, no, you buy it. And I said, no, no, no. We're gonna see if Santa goes, Dada, you buy it. But how old? How old is he? He's three and a half.
Oh. Yeah. Now, what do you think is too old to be still 2.5. Oh! Yeah. 2.5. 2.5. I know. What do you think is too old to be still in the Santa world? I'm saying this gently, because I don't know how young our listeners are. I feel is when they're ready. Yeah, when they're ready.
When they're ready, when they're ready, and maybe your son is ready now. I know, does it help? I know, it's a little shocking, but when they're ready, they're gonna ask in a different way. He doesn't think that I'm Santa. No, no, no, he's just saying that he doesn't want to wait
for Santa. Look at this guy, look at this guy. Oh, adorable. Was he on the potty there? I love it. He looks very excited about his movement. He's, daddy, look. Believe me, he's, I asked him this morning also,
I'm not gonna get to it in the week, but I asked him who's the boss and he said me. I said, you're not the boss anyway. I remember in Christmas, like my mom used to get us so much more in debt than we already were. Right, Christmas was like the number one thing in her life. She would max out her credit cards and mortgage the house just so we could have presents.
And as I got older, I'm like, I don't know if this is the greatest business model for our home. Like maybe. You're leaving us with another gift too, mom. That's debt. Yeah. By the way, it's a very sort of,
it's very much symbolic of like sort of the age that we live in. You watch these ads up now on TV and they're all like, everybody's gonna go to one of these big box stores and they're like, well, dad needs a CD player. My son needs a new big screen TV. And I'm like, what kind of money do people have that they're spending like? You know what I mean? Like having these huge, it seems crazy.
Anyway, I don't want to get it. I also remember really quick, just while we're on the subject, my mom constantly with a cigarette hanging out of her mouth, constantly 24 hours a day filling the stockings by the fire. And then by the tree that was real with her lit cigarette, just putting stuff under the tree. That was my dad too. Really?
Really? Smoking in the house and doctors telling him, you have to quit. And he was saying to us, this is a complot of the family is not true that I have to quit You are all talking to the doctor What a character how is this the smoking in Europe? Still a lot of smokers in Europe correct much less much less
I mean I grew up in a spending time every day in a hair salon because my mom owned a hair salon Everyone was smoking in front of all the kids. The combination of that, plus all the toxicity of all the products. Can you imagine? You can smoke in the elevator over in Europe. No, no, it was... There's ashtrays in the elevators. When?
Yeah, when I was in Paris a couple of years ago, there were still ashtrays in the elevators. I don't know, I think it's like now or in every... No, no bien sûr. Je ne sais pas, je pense que c'est pas vrai. Non, c'est pas vrai. Non, c'est pas encore. Non, non, bien sûr. Pas du tout, pas du tout. Non, non, non, non. Wait a second, Penelope,
comment de nombreuses langues, tu sais, tout le monde qui vit en France sait comme cinq langues. Oui. Je parle italien, spanish, anglais, avec cet accent, que je ne sais pas quand,
je vais le faire. Et je suis petit, oui. Oh, mon Dieu, on peut parler français. Ah, OK. Si tu veux, mais... J'ai pas essayé. Oui, moi aussi. Bon, bon, qu'est-ce que vous voulez? C'est une petite édition. C'est pas français, c'est bien. Je peux l'entendre.
Ah, bien sûr. Alors, Penelope, vous savez, j'ai bien entendu, c'est un plaisir de vous rencontrer. C'est très bien que vous ayez fait le show. Je l'aime, c'est très bien. Je l'aime, c'est très bien. Je Penelope, you know, obviously I don't know you. It's such a pleasure to meet you. It's so nice you're doing the show.
Thank you. No, I love it. This is so much fun. I could be here for five hours straight. Okay, great. Well, we have two minutes. So, no, I'm kidding. Where are you going?
No, we have. Sean, believe me, Sean has eight hours that he needs to fill today. So this is perfect. If you could just stick around until seven tonight. No, it seems like, you know, there's certain points in my life that I can remember changed me and I grew from.
I'm gonna sneeze at you! Sorry. Oh, I love that. You can't announce it. That was the best. There's our first ever sneeze. That is, I love that. Sometimes I sneeze eight times in a row.
Oh my God, I hope not. It's always three. That's gonna happen. I did it today. I did it this morning too. I think it's going around. I sneeze like. What about people who muffled their sneezes?
It's my favorite thing to do. And people that stifle them, I'm like, no. I can't. Just let it out. You're depriving yourself of one of the greatest releases ever. Yeah, that was to be bad for you. Yeah, I'm sorry guys. Yeah, sneeze edging is no good.
All right, keep going Sean. What was your, Sean, keep going. My thing was there's certain points in my life that I can recall changed me, where I grew from them, where I learned and they were- Fill and joke here. Yeah. They were experiences that made me grow up quickly and realize and see things differently.
And you seem like, not again, not knowing you, you seem like you have an amazing no bullshit meter. Like you're- Oh, thank you. That's a great compliment. You can call it out right away. Were there certain moments in your life that taught you that, that you can remember,
you're like, you know what, because of this experience, I have now changed and I'm gonna call you on that now, so it doesn't happen to me again. Yes, a few things, like crucial moments in my life that I remember that were like a turning point in terms of like, oh, actually, you can respect yourself that much and it's okay. No, and it's not just okay.
I feel so much happier. And moments like this are, I feel like if you get to live a long life, those things you remember before you go, I'm sure. Yeah, do you remember what some of those are or what moments, if you wanna share them? For example, working with Michael, was very interesting that way because he's very, very tough.
And I loved, we didn't have a lot of free time there. We were working really hard and nonstop, but sometimes if we had 10 minutes in between shots, I just wanted to talk to him about, without calling it that in front of him, but it was about his toughness, about the reasons why he has no problem saying no, which is sometimes harder for me.
And he said, he answered something so brilliant. He said, you know, there is no free lunch. There is so much in that answer that I needed to hear. There's no free lunch. That advice. Yeah, there is no free lunch, meaning like if, I don't wanna give a specific example, but there are times in your life when you know,
you have to say no to something and so many justifications and all, but this, but that will make you say, yes, you don't want to hurt somebody's feelings, you don't want to, no, no, no, no, it's too complicated. But you feel like what's the right thing to do. And he's very honest that way and has no problem saying. And then you're like, oh, I didn't know
that it's okay for me to say no. Yeah, well, that's a boundary thing, right? That's like a boundary. It's a boundary thing, meaning there is no freelance. If you don't say no when you know you have to and you accumulate too many of those, one day you're gonna explode. I know, because I had to learn that too.
Well, I'd say I'm here and JB, we, Sean, you and I talked about with JB. I said, within the last year, Jason, I said to you, I really respect your ability to draw boundaries for yourself. You've gotten, you're really good. You really set a good example for me. I think it took me to get older to understand.
And it is, Penelope, like you say, when you start to be able to say no or to draw a boundary and say, this is my boundary, it's so freeing because you feel you take a little bit of power back and you're able to go like, yeah, that's not okay for me. Yeah. And then, you know. It's very difficult to learn that. Yeah. Also as an actor, when actress starting very young, when you depend on others to say yes to you to work,
and then you realize that, oh, maybe I have to say no, for example, to this project. And how can I allow myself to say no to that? That's also a huge lesson. Yeah. Thank you for saying that, Will. But one of the things that I worry about is that I just, that I get meaner
or that think people will think, oh well, he's being mean or that's, right, or he's cranky. And while that might be the case, to compensate for that, I have expanded my nice side. When there are moments that I feel like I should be nicer or I should be generous in this moment or do that thing.
I end up doing more of those things and being nicer when it is time to be nice. I see you making that. I've seen you making the effort lately. I swear to God, I'm not kidding. It's not about the no, it's about how you say the no. Yeah. How you say it and what you're saying Jason is just more honest.
Yeah. And that doesn't make you meaner. You're just more honest because behind a lot of yeses that you don't want to say there is that. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There is no way. I learned that lesson and I'm not going back to where I was. Yeah. By the way, we are still owed seven more sneezes.
Yeah. I know, but it's not happening. We'll wait. We'll be right back. SmartList gets support from ShipStation. The beginning of the year is a great time to grow your business, but if you're stuck in the trenches of daily tasks,
like managing order fulfillment, you're not able to focus on what really matters, increasing sales. ShipStation easily automates shipping tasks and manages orders in one simple dashboard. Their effortless integration is everywhere you sell online, including Amazon, Etsy, eBay, Shopify, and more. Simplify and automate your shipping no matter how big your business grows. Ship Station has enterprise solutions that reduce warehouse costs and improve profitability. Over 130,000 companies have grown their e-commerce businesses with Ship Station, and 98% of companies that stick with Ship Station for a year become customers for life. Make this year your most profitable one yet with Ship Station. Use promo code smartless today at ShipStation.com to sign up for your free 30-day trial
at ShipStation.com promo code smartless. [♪ music playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing of content with bestsellers, new releases, and exclusive originals that get you closer to the voices that can change your life. You'll find voices that motivate, sounds to soothe, stories to inspire, and personalities to encourage you along the way. You know what I checked out recently? I checked out something called Fluke. Chance, chaos, and why everything we do matters. It's called Fluke. It's really cool. It's by this social scientist, Brian Kloss. What he does, he dives deeply into the phenomenon of random chance and the chaos it can sow, taking aim at most people's neat and tidy storybook version of reality. It's really, really cool. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. New
members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from HelloFresh. Whether your resolution is to save money, eat better or stress less,
HelloFresh is here to help you do all three. Say hello to your most delicious year yet with fresh ingredients and chefcrafted recipes at a price you'll like delivered right to your door. Each HelloFresh box is packed with farm fresh ingredients and everything arrives pre-portioned right to your doorstep for less hassle and less wasted food. So you're resolved to actually sit down and eat dinner around the table,
but what do you do about those nights when your schedule is packed? Turn to HelloFresh's lineup of quick and easy meals, including their 15 minute recipes designed to help minimize mealtime stress. So you know what I love? I love the rapid stir-fry beef. You know why?
It's rapid like me and it's a little spicy like me. Hello, HelloFresh. Go to HelloFresh.com slash SmartLessFree and use code SmartLessFree for free breakfast for life. One breakfast item per box while subscription is active. Get free breakfast for life and support the show while you're at it. Just go to HelloFresh.com slash SmartLessFree
with code SmartLessFree. HelloFresh, America's number one meal kit. And now back to the show. One of our friends gave us a good tip, they said, because someone will ask you, hey, next month, would you mind coming over to my place and helping me out with such and such? You might say, sure, yeah, because it's a month away.
And then the day comes, and you're like, oh, I can't believe I said yes to that. This person said, here's what you do. If you have to imagine that it's for tomorrow, if you don't wanna do something tomorrow, That's your answer. Say no today. You just imagine that it's tomorrow.
If you don't wanna do it tomorrow, then go ahead and say no today. Yeah, yeah. And you're right, you replace it with tomorrow. It's kind of a good, I wanna ask you, this is gonna be sort of, I'm veering way off topic, but it's gonna ask you to do something in a few months and just pretend it's not.
I'm just gonna say no. I'm just, no, okay. Where's Lizzie? Okay, it's a bag with 30 million euros in it, but I guess no. No, I was gonna ask you about, I love Madrid, I've been there a few times, I think it's really such a phenomenal city,
and I really love Spain. And one of my great nights that I had in Madrid was with an old friend of mine who lives there, who's lived there for 20, 25 years, different business, finance, good guy to know. But he took me out, we went for drinks, then we went to an Atletico Madrid game, and then we went for dinner.
It was a Sunday night, and we sat down for dinner at about 11 p.m. Oh God, I'm out. And it was just starting to fill up. In the families, it was that very famous restaurant where everybody goes, I forget what it's called, but it's a very sort of fancy. And it was like, and I know that like, I don't know if the prince or the king still goes there,
but he used to. It was like one of the, and the families would come in, 10 people in the family, the kids, everybody. I left at one o'clock, I said an early flight the next day and I'm like, I can't believe how. Why is that? Why is it always so late? Like it just sounds like a bunch of acid refluxed that in early flight the next day and I'm like, I can't believe how. Why is that? Why is it always so late?
Like it just sounds like a bunch of acid reflux. Yeah. That was my schedule before, before having a family. You know, it was like normal to go to dinner at 10 with your friends or with family. But not, I mean, schools in Spain start like early, like here, like around 8.30 or 8.
And you can have that schedule. Maybe sometimes in the weekend, but that's more for single people. Is Spain the, like the other, I've never been to Spain and I wanna go really bad. Maybe you've never been. I wanna go. No, is it kinda like, is that the country
or the side of the world that doesn't get dark until like 10 or 11 at night or something like that? No, you gotta go north all the time. In the summer, we have light until 10. No way. In the summer, we do. But then further north you go, Sean. Beautiful.
The lighter it stays later. This is so, I'm so sorry. Yeah, the Delpy, we're sorry. This is a little bit of a charity hire. No, no, no. Yeah, he wanted to get into radio. He just wants to experience the light of Madrid in the summer. Yeah, so Penelope, now here you are, you're here in America and you're doing all this stuff for Ferrari,
which is, first of all, Michael Mann, of course, one of the all-time great directors. Yeah. just one of the all time great directors. But you're here, you're in America and you're doing all the stuff that goes with that. Yeah, this is what I love. The press tour, which includes talking to us, I imagine. But how, what is that like for you? Like how do you sort of gear up for that with your life and everything that's going on with the kids
and you gotta go like, all right, I gotta go do all the junkets. I got it, yeah, I got it. Do you like that stuff or is it okay? As you know, it's part of it. And I just do like very short trips, like went to New York for one day for the Gotham Awards and then back home and then London one day and a half
back home. Now we're here for a couple of days. I rather do it like this, you know, than putting together a long trip. Ideally, would you do one job a year or two jobs a year? Do you try to keep? That changed a lot. I used to do like four movies per year
and travel nonstop. And now I do like one per year and they're not too long. And what I can do one in Madrid while the school is happening, I maybe would do that one and one in the summer so we can travel all together. And this is like the, I feel very privileged and very lucky to be able to do it that way
because I feel like all of those years working so hard have given me the opportunity to be able to choose what I want to do now and be a little bit like the owner, more or less of my own schedule. Even if you know how things always change, if they tell you you're gonna start in March, probably you're gonna start a month later. But even like counting with that
and knowing that that will always be the nature of our profession. Feeling like I kind of own a big part of my time is such a blessing. Yeah. Such a blessing because like I told you before, my priority is raising my children. So, and I feel so lucky that I can combine that with my work. Yeah, it's so cool to be able to shift that perspective from when you're younger and you're like you were saying,
like you're trying to make a mark, you're trying to do as much stuff as you can. You want to work with directors, you want to work on different projects. And then you get older and you're like, yeah, that stuff's not as important to me anymore. I mean, it's a luxury, obviously, but... Yeah, it is, it is.
I mean, I don't take it for granted. And I also still love so much, like preparing a character, the research process, and being on the set, and the creativity, and how that makes me feel like searching for answers. And I still feel like the little girl that was watching the Betamax. Yeah. What was your first Hollywood film? What was your first big? It was Stephen Frears, a movie called High Low Country,
and I was obsessed with him because of the grifters and Dangerously A Song. So that was also a phone call that made me so happy. Can I ask you a dorky actor question? Because you're such a great actor. You're very... I'm new question, because you're such a great actor. You're very... You too, thank you so much. No, no, you really are.
There's, I find myself when I watch you play a character, I'm leaning in, I'm trying to read your mind. You're not, it's great. You don't help the audience. You're very internal and that's my favorite kind. But I think sometimes that it would be hard for me to manage that kind of subtlety with an accent. I wonder if I would be, is it easier for you
when you're playing a character that's speaking Spanish versus English because oftentimes the difference between a good performance and a bad performance will be in the way in which lines are said, in the meter, and what like you can say, I love you a million different ways, and an accent can change what an intention sounds like. I love you, I love you, I love you.
And oftentimes an accent is that, it changes. We're gonna go a different way. The rhythm of something Do you have to manage that at all? Is it do you even think about it? So I think about it a lot because I I feel very lucky that I'm able to do movies in four languages and a lot of different accents For example with Spanish language a lot of different accents and I feel like is sometimes I don't want to call it a disadvantage to have an accent because at the end of the day for me in my career it has given me more advantages
than the opposite because it has opened so many doors to be able to play so many different nationalities And I don't know that I could now get to play a character that has English as her first language. Maybe someday we could get to that. But would I change that but not being able to play an Italian or a French or all the characters that I can play in English that can be from so many nationalities, but like I said, maybe English is not their first language. When I'm working in Spanish, of course, it's going to be like a freedom that you're not going to have when you are working in a different language, but it's not always that way because sometimes when I'm working with a different language or accent, I don't hear myself, I don't recognize
myself and that already gives me a space of distance between myself to create somebody new that actually is very helpful for me. So I mean I keep working with, I'm always with a dialect coach in my life. I've, lately I work with Tim Monic, who is incredible. I feel like I've heard of him. And I've had so many teachers in, for all different languages and accents or go to the place and spend time there. And you feel like you have as much control
over your intention when you're reading a line, even though you might be working with an accent, versus the kind of control you have when you're working in Spanish. You feel like it's equal enough? I feel like if I put a lot, a lot of time into it, so that I get to a place where I don't have to be thinking about it, I will have the advantages of having that distance between myself and the way that character speaks and not recognizing myself when I speak. And I enjoy that very much. But for example, I'm making a movie in the spring in English and I start to work now in January
and it's gonna be like every day, putting many hours into it, so that I don't have to be thinking about it when I'm there, so you just can, so it becomes part of you. And that character would have an American accent or a Spanish accent? No.
It will have a Spanish accent, but we want it to be as always as clear as possible. And just so there's no gap there, so that it's much more immediate is what you're saying. Yeah, but the gap that is the accent or acting in another language sometimes helps so much to create that distance and... ...allows you to enter a different person.
Can I ask you, when you won, I think it was 2008 maybe, when you won Academy Award for Vicki Christina, right? Is that 2008, something like that? I think it was 2008. Maybe 2009, something like that for Vicki Christina, Barcelona. When you won, because this is always like a sort of a trippy thing, it's kind of like you win the great Academy Award.
Did you feel that kind of, was it euphoric in the moment? Was it let down? Did it change anything or did you go, or was it, you know, what was that sort of feeling? Was the moment as you imagined it? Yeah, yeah. Wow, it was the first one of the night. So I was happy about that because my heart was going so fast.
I don't know how I could have gone through hours of that, but it was incredible to be able to hug my mother there. I was sad my father wasn't there because they were not together as a couple. So they would take turns. And he came to some awards, he came to others and all their family and friends were there and I just, the thing is that I only remember like 30% of it because the adrenaline was so high and I remember like right after winning calling my
father and calling Pedro and I remember- Pedro was, oh, this girl will not leave me alone. Exactly. And I remember going after the ceremony, we went to In-N-Out. Of course, with the gown and all. And then we went to Gaius Sirius House, who is a very good friend of mine. And I'm sure you've been in that party.
I walked in and I looked to my left and in a sofa together. There was Jack Nicholson, Scorsese, Harvey K. Tell, Robert De Niro, Al Pacino, and I was like, oh, can't handle that. And I was like, the other way, I was like, I got so nervous. That image was like, oh, I should have taken a picture of that image, all of them together.
Guy can pack a house. Yeah. That, I was gonna ask you a bit ago, but that's a perfect segue. You know, you said you lived here for 15 years, but what are some of the, and then, but when you come visit, what are the some of the things you look forward to?
Eating like in and out, or seeing or experiencing? Like do you miss anything that you get excited about here? I have a group of friends that we get together and we play wolves, wolves and villagers. Do you know the game, right? Of course, of course. And I'm sure you know some of the players.
And oh my God, and you know everyone ends up like so angry with each other for weeks because you just have to lie and betray other people in this game. And it's a really good game for actors. And it's one of the things that I try to do when I come back to LA, like get together with the Wolf players that I have here.
And we play a lot in Spain also. You can play it on Zoom too. Have you ever played it on Zoom? No, no. Yeah, you can play it on Zoom. Interesting. Yeah, you can do it on, I think over COVID there was a lot of mafia on Zoom. Interesting.
Really? I have a team of players in Madrid, like many friends that are obsessed with the game like I am. And then other team of players here. There's a show based on it Penelope called Traders. And it's based on that. From the UK. From the UK version and American version and Australian version.
And now a friend of mine did a Spanish version of the show. Oh really? Sergio Peris Mencheta. It's interesting. What's something that people don't know that you do, like a sort of guilty pleasure or something that you, like do you like watch Bad Reality TV? This is, I feel like Jason,
I'm getting into your territory with this question. We love this question. We love this question. Like what do you do? Do you, are you secretly a golfer? Do you play tennis? Do you have some obsessions? I don't know.
You like to doodle. Well, I love a good massage, I have to say. Oh my God. Wow. I would have a massage every day. That's one of the best treats that you do. How I would like to, every single day. Do you get a massage once a week?
No, but I don't know. Once a month. Maybe once a month, once a month. But I love it. I hurt my back in the shower, actually, the other day. Just doing? Yeah, just like trying to wash my feet, just reaching down to visit, and out it goes.
So I got a massage last night. It was so deep and so painful. I hurt more today than I did yesterday. But it's all different. It's all, I'm just sore from, so sometimes it can be a little too hard. Yes, Penelope? I don't know.
It's one of my, I don't know, what can you call it? It's a hobby. What can you call it? It's a passion. It's a passion. It's a treat. It's a treat. And I love knitting.
Oh, you do? Oh, you do. Yeah, starting to do that with my daughter because my grandmother taught me how to do that and sewing and I love cooking because with my job it's not that I can cook every day but it's something that I really like and I don't have a lot of, actually like a lot of social life and I don't really go out, I don't drink. I have strange hobbies also. Or like?
I don't know why I always end up talking about this in interviews, but I love reading about medicine. I do too. I do too. Why are you hypercontact? Yes, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. That's true. You do, I love when I find somebody that can discuss endocrine system. I'm like, oh, best friend. Sean is on a VIP program. This is not a joke at Cedars because he's so obsessed with his own, right? Am I, I'm not, he has his own entrance. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, you and I best friends. Yes, I mean, I'm obsessed. But do you both, do you both worry about mortality? his own entrance. Yeah. Yeah. You and I best friends. Yes. I'm obsessed. But do you both worry about mortality? Do you feel like it's... It's not about mortality.
It's about suffering. Yes. It's not about mortality. It's about suffering. I don't want to catch it. Tell me how did you get it? How do I avoid it? You know, all that.
Yes, yes, yes. Were you both very nervous about COVID when COVID was around? Were you both nervous about that? I was more nervous for other people, for older or for children. Obviously, we didn't know what was gonna happen and I was worried for my mom. Did everybody get COVID?
I did, I did go COVID. Sean, did you get it? You still haven't had it, right, Will? I've never had it, no. Oh my God. But Penelope, I'm go COVID. Sean, did you get it? You still haven't had it, right? Well, I've never had it, no. Oh my God. But Penelope, I'm more worried about like, like if I, if like my stomach hurts or like my eye hurt, I'm like, oh my God, I have cancer, I'm gonna die
or like whatever, I go from zero to a hundred and then I have to read all about it and like. But you, why should be you scared? You've got an extra eye, don't you? The thing is that you have to know where to read it. And when you do this, you end up knowing where to go. It's not like, doesn't it happen to you? Like if you go to the doctor with the right questions
and they tell you, you're not one of those that is reading everything on internet. And it's like, what depends if you go to the right places, you actually can come here with the right questions. It doesn't mean you go to the doctor with the answers, but you go with the right questions and sometimes they don't like that. That's right. That's right.
My doctor is like, yeah, look it up online. He always says that. Does he really? It sounds pretty lazy. If you're being like, or take a picture and text it to me. That's what he says. Well, listen, Penelope, we have taken up way too much of your time. It's such an honor having you here and to join us.
Yeah, it's so nice of you to join us. I love this. You said earlier to me that I need to experience the light of Madrid and I think I just did. Oh, no, I had so much fun talking to you right here. I feel it's too short. You shined your light on us. It is too short. I had so much fun in this conversation right here. I feel it's too short. You shine your light on us. It is too short. I had so much fun in this conversation.
We'll continue at a Madrid. Next time we're down to Madrid, we're gonna look you up. We're gonna have an 11 PM dinner on a Sunday night. You're gonna cook for us. Yes, I will if you want. Yes. We'll do it. Well listen, continued success really.
And congratulations to your trip. Enjoy your trip, your holidays, get back to the family. And I can't wait for Ferrari. Yeah, we can't wait. Yeah, we're looking forward to that. Thank you, thank you so much. Yeah, we're such fans. Thank you.
You've been really kind, thank you so much. Thank you, Penelope. Thank you, bye. Bye-bye. Fuck, I'm fucking, look at this. Oh, look at that. You were so, Penelope was so great, you're sweating. I know, that was, I mean, gosh, right?
Penelope Cruz. I didn't know what to do. I'm such a fan, I've never met her or anything and I didn't know what to expect. I know, me neither. And now I'm like a bigger fan. Like she's really fun and easy. I was hoping that she was gonna be as charming
and as wonderful as she seems to be, right? Did she ever play that game where you watch people on talk shows and stuff like that, and you're just a fan of theirs and you feel like, like what she was saying about Pedro Almotovar, I think that's how you say it, like she could just tell, boy, if we ever met we'd really get along. I played that sometimes, I looked at people, I was like, you know what, I bet she'd be awesome. I think a lot of people do think that sometimes
in the general public and they're like psychotic a little bit, but she's not because she's actually legitimately great. Well, you were getting a psycho vibe when you'd watch her. Not from her. I'm saying that the people, you know, there are people who watch moves and go like, I would be best friends with Jason Bateman.
I will go and wait for him. I will wait for him and we will be, you know what I mean? But Sean, you kind of said it like, it's a little different when we will be, you know what I mean? But Sean, you kind of said it like it's a little different when it's her, you know, she shows up and you're like, um, yeah, okay, yeah, feel free to hang out. I want to see that movie. I want to see that movie.
I know I want to see Ferrari so bad. I know me too. I love. I like Adam. I like her. I like Michael Mann and I do like cars. Cars, you know? I mean, I don't know if I'd ever be able to pull off owning one,
but I do. I do. Now you got to have a certain, you kind of got to have a certain thing to be able to own a Ferrari. Yeah. Hey, Will, you ever owned a Ferrari? Funnily enough, I have, but the point is an old one, an old one, not like a classic. No, I don't like, not like one of these douchebags who drives drives around you know, LA and one of those, you know, sure
Yeah, I've never I've never been in one. I've only seen them drive by oh Shawnee snuck it right through Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass. SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barberco. Smart. Lass. SmartLess. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondry Plus
in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondry.com. Academy is a new scripted podcast that follows Ava Richards, played by HBO's Industries, www.candry.com.au student to make the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top 10, curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of.
But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death. Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.